my name is Tom I'm one of the developers
of stone hearth our first game as a
studio it is a simulation strategy game
set in a medieval voxel II kind of
16-bit world so when I start the game I
get to pick who I want to play kind of
the actual game or just you wanna do I
just want to chill out and not have
threats like combat or starvation and
things like that I'll take a normal game
and the world of stone hearth is
procedurally generated so we have
forests in mountains and Plains and
those are all sort of built on you know
sort of a mathematical model to simulate
the real world but then kind of you know
take it down to sort of a 16-bit feel so
as I mouse over the map I can pick or I
can see sort of on the right the kinds
of resources that will be available to
me trees and plants are really important
to build things Wood is the most
important resource in in our game and
then there are other resources like
wildlife will to provide food and things
like that and then minerals which you'll
need to sort of go up the tech tree and
advance to something that's like stone
or or you know what I mean
so we can get going here and now the
game in the background is of course
building our map making those
so I'm looking at the game looking at
the map it feels like there's kind of a
a SimCity vibe and the graph is kind of
Minecraft II what were the inspirations
yeah so from a gameplay perspective our
number one inspiration is definitely
Dwarf Fortress we want a game where it's
very much
sandbox sim we're sort of putting in a
lot of very sophisticated simulations
and then letting you sort of play around
with them it's a game about building
towns where it's war fortresses if
you've heard of that game it's about
building sort of uh you know
subterranean caverns we're sort of
focused above-ground but we definitely
have mining as well and then
aesthetically we're going for sort of a
16-bit RPG feel where we want you to
feel like you're sort of building one of
the towns that you might have visit if
you've played like an old 16-bit RPG so
I've got my initial band of settlers
here and in this game I never direct any
of them directly I always sort of
orchestrate and tell them what to do and
then they figure out a way to do it each
one of my settlers is randomly generated
and we're sort of bringing in RPG light
mechanics to sort of a simulation game
so they have their name each one has
their own statistics mind/body/spirit
they have equipment they have their own
personality and the first thing I need
to do when I get going in the game is
harvest some resources so like I said
wood as our primary resource so I'll
tell them to chop down some trees and
over here I've set up a stockpile so
that'll tell them to pick up stuff off
the ground and store it over here and I
can sort of set up what I want to store
in this thing right now I'll just have
everything so after resource gathering I
can actually start to build things and
we really want this to be a game where
you can build whatever you want but we
understand that not everyone is an
artist so I can start with sort of a
template that I've got so I can say take
a little cottage and just sort of rotate
it right way and stamp it down
I I get an overview of what this thing
is going to cost it's gonna cost some
wood and some other things and then I
can tell my little guys to build it and
when they do they're gonna build this
building Vaslav axle and this is what we
think is one of the core appeals of the
game that your little settlers are
really smart and we don't fake anything
in this simulation so they're digging
out the foundation and then you'll see
them sort of build up the columns and
then they'll eventually build up the
rest of the building now to finish my
house I need to do things like make a
door in a window and some beds and to do
that I'll need to specialize some of my
workers so right now all these you can
see in the in the corner here that the
worker class and the worker is sort of
an unspecialized based hauler and
builder you can't really do much but I
can take one of them and you can see we
have a saw here I can specialize my
workers by giving them a tool so I'll
grab a timber over here and change his
class you can see we have lots of
classes available some are available now
others will be available later and
because I have a saw I can turn him into
a carpenter and when I do that sort of
one over here grab his saw and promote
himself the timber is now a carpenter
and so by the merits of being the
carpenter to give him new abilities so
he has the ability to make a workshop
sort of do that and now from his
workshop he can craft a lot of stuff so
here all the rest feats he has access to
first he has tools and weapons and I can
use these tools to further specialize my
citizens sort of the pattern is you take
a worker and you give them a tool and
that specializes it into sort of a a
specialized class a little RPG light
stuff so I can make a hoe so that we can
have some farmers and then I will make
sort of the things that I need
to build this house I'm gonna need
couple windows and a couple of beds just
jam those out and so my carpenter is
crafting my builders are building now
the next thing I need to worry about is
probably a food supply so to do that I
will specialize another one of my
citizens with this trappers knife so
let's grab see who are you
vo vo would make a great rapper I don't
know that but I'm guessing if I really
wanted to sort of be very careful about
this I could sort of look at her stats
and say oh you know she has four body
stat which is above our average social
be kind of smash faster than average I
can tell that because their speed
attribute is sort of based on her body
attribute so she would make a good
trapper because the trapper sort of is
gonna be doing a lot of running around
the characters level all right so the
characters level up just by doing their
normal activities so as timber is
crafting things he'll level up and we
actually have a set of perks that you
get as you level up so by virtue of
being level one we start at level zero
tipper can now craft more stuff as he
goes up different levels you'll be able
to make more rare items and eventually
even upgrade into future classes so
that's sort of the way that we handle
our tech tree rather than researching
you sort of level up your citizens and
an RPG light type way
looks like I'm almost out of wood so let
me chop down one more tree and now I
have a trapper but how does she trap
well because we don't you never direct
your citizens directly it's sort of more
about planning your planning out sort of
the layout of your town and how it's
going to work we use zones so I can say
hey I'm gonna zone this area of ground
to be for trapping and when I do that
vo our trapper will sort of run over
there and say okay she's gonna look for
prey and so she sort of surveys the
landscape right that wasn't a good spot
but she's looking for a place to drop
some traps to catch some critters so
she's sort of setting out her traps and
she'll do that automatically if I want
to I can turn the zone off when I don't
want her to do that
but now she's sort of off and going off
on her own doing what she needs to do so
this is sort of the core mechanic of the
game the way we think of your citizens
are almost like let's see what can you
do
let's make some more stuff lanterns
we're gonna need those so you mentioned
people are also able to craft their and
create their own things yeah exactly so
this is at a building that I just
slapped down because whatever it looks
good and you know I want to do it
quickly if I want to take more time I
can take as much time as I need to
implement or to my own plan so this is
our building designer tool and you can
like sort of drag out a floor plan so
say I want maybe like an N type of a
building I can sort of just drag out
boxes and we we liken this to drawing a
graph paper that's sort of the way we
want it to feel and then once I have
that I can quickly raise walls around it
okay and then say I wanted this to be
like a really big tablet I can draw a
second level over here and then just
really you know sort of quickly using
these primitives just you know build up
the building right I want to edit pieces
I can sort of change the roof color do
whatever I want
carve in doors and windows
so they're just gonna put the stairs in
automatically no so right right now we
don't support stairs we will very soon
but for now if I wanted to have stairs
for the second level I could like sort
of put them in myself so carve out hole
here and then draw the stairs in so the
tools that have been showing you so far
are sort of like our macros sort of
helpers but we do have freeform I get
some voxel editing so I can come in here
and just like you know add if I want a
dad I don't know like some kind of like
symbol on top of this thing right I can
just come in and click click click like
right and so through a combination of I
guess the macro tools and you know voxel
live voxel editing you can really sort
of make whatever you wanted here I made
kind of an ugly tavern when I'm finished
I'll get an overview oh this is what
you've said to build this is the
resource cost build it but what we've
seen players building already is like
you know all kinds of stuff from like
statues to pirate ships to you know
anything that you can sort of put
together in your head they'll figure out
how to build and then let's see how it
made hoes I didn't mean to make this
let's make some lanterns there we go so
I mean the core of the game in the
beginning is just getting a foothold
figuring out how you're gonna supply
food to your settlers figurative the
right balance between food and defense
and actually building things which is
kind of the fun part and it's sort of
like an RTS trade-off very light RTS
style mechanics where it's going focus
an army do a focus on the economy and
how that plays out in the rest of the
game will be determined of will be
determined by you know where you chose
to settle is this a place that's easily
defended am i doing things that will
attract enemies so there's some kind of
danger as well that's right there is
some kind of danger so we have sort of
what we call an AI Game Master running
around in the background who's
constantly looking at what you're
building how many people do you have
what's the overall net worth of your
town where did you actually choose to
settle and based on all those factors
the gamemaster will throw sort of
scripted encounters at you and it could
be like a trader who wants to trade with
you or it could be something dangerous
like a band of goblins that has come to
basically take your stuff or you know we
have a very lightweight diplomacy well
maybe they'll come and say oh you have
some things that we want would you like
to give those things to us and then
you'll love the choice so yeah so this
is sort of the start of the game I have
a previous game that I've got queued up
which is from maybe like about six hours
of play and this is a town where I've
expanded up to twelve settlers and built
a couple of buildings and just to show
off and sort of all the features we have
in the game so here's a farmer and she's
got some we've got fields of pumpkins
and corn and whatever I think those are
turnips and that's my primary food
supply which has allowed me to get up to
12 settlers and then over here we have
sort of a bigger keep I can hit this
button to look inside the buildings so I
built this sort of two-story building
and the bottom story is set up to be a
vault so I have sort of a bunch of
chests of gold coins that have gone by
trading with surrounding merchants and
then although we are focused on
above-ground building we do support
mining so if we go way over here I'll
slice into the world I've set up sort of
uh I guess subterranean cavern here or
we've got like kind of a dorm going and
a bunch of fun things so if you want to
focus on above-ground building houses
and stuff that's cool if you want to go
below ground and sort of carve into the
mountains
that's up to you as well and then you
mentioned danger so over here so this is
my town
doing pretty good we're here is a band
of goblins that have set up shop
specifically to sort of take my stuff
and they have a mini boss Keith's red
blood painter and I can sort of look at
what he's want so he came to me and he
said you know
where's our stuff right so you wanted me
to give them a little bit tint or and
some squirrel pelts and I don't have the
stuff for them so at this point I have
to say you know what I don't have it so
right there's a little bit of dialogue
aha
and at this point I'm sort of at war
with the goblins and they won't do
anything right away not not something so
I guess obvious but at this point they
will every now and then send raids to
you know take the stuff that I refuse to
give them and that's sort of you know
how we're introducing combat in the game
it's definitely a game about sort of
creative building and exploring
simulation like you know the water
simulation and things like that but we
do have a combat element but it's not an
RTS it's not really about the combat the
combats just sort of there to give a
sense of danger and drive the story of
your town when you're leveling up
characters can they can they have
multiple classes does your leveling
carry a cross like a single one so if
you switch a class do you have to start
from the beginning or yeah so your
characters can each occupy one class at
one time but you can change that so this
point Pony is a footman she's a level
one footman so she's done you know a
little bit of fighting I can change her
to you know a farmer and at which point
she'll sort of put down her sword and
you know pick up pick up of the trial or
the hoe and now she's a farmer and she
could change back and look she still has
her shield that's a bit of a bug great
but her level is separate between farmer
and footman right and so we want you to
be able to like move now she's going off
and doing farming things with their
shield gaming experience bit by bit four
of the crops she gets the the trick is
the experience you need to reach state
level one to level two that goes up per
level of every class so because she's
already leveled up a few levels as a
footman it's gonna take a longer to
achieve that next level
as a farmer so we're trying to strike a
balance between live giving you the
flexibility to move people around but
not making the best way to play the game
to like make everyone a farmer when you
need food and then when you know an
invasion comes turn everyone into a
footman with no penalty so we want you
to make choices but the choices don't
have to be like you know pulley final
[Music]
yeah one thing about your characters is
that we really want you to think of them
that'll like you know individual human
beings and give them a lot of
personality so they all keep a journal
and this is sort of the sum of all their
journals put together what they like
about your town what they would improve
and so if you really want to sort of if
you're a min/max ER and you really want
to get like the highest morale and have
everybody be super happy this is
something that you can look at and see
you know what what do people need this
is something that you can't ignore and
still you know play the game just fine
but you know if you're all about sort of
maxing out you know our scores and right
now we keep track of your net worth a
happier people how well are they fed and
how well are they sheltered is the
benefit the benefit so these are
requirements to get in new citizens if
you pay no attention to this you'll see
stuck at seven for the whole game and
eventually people started death so
that's no good
so beyond like expanding your town your
citizens will start to do things when
they are particularly happy if they're
really happy and you have a great food
supply if you'll sort of join together
and hold like a feast so we call those
festivals and it's really kind of I
guess ambient behavior new ambient
behaviors that they'll do as a reward
for you like you know doing something
particularly well it's a game that's I
don't want to say it's hard to lose but
if you pay attention and you're you know
you're paying attention to your town
you're not gonna get like plugged over
the head you know five hours into the
game and it's game over
it's it's it's sort of we want to keep
you on your toes but not give you
really challenging content it really is
sort of a game that that I think of is
kind of Zen where it's like let me build
and and explore and just sort of have
fun well so the game is called stone
hearth I think a lot of people Raleigh
automatically make a connection to
hearthstone and maybe just assume by the
name that it is a card game knockoff of
some type I why did you decide to to
stay with stone hearth and are you
concerned at all about that being
confusing yeah
so we names Joanne hearth back in 2012
came up with the name loved it it took
us a long time to come up with a name
and then six months later or something
we got out of a blue card game which was
and it's disappointing and so we
announced on our blog hey we're gonna
change the name and our fan said no
don't change the names don't know
there's a perfect game we love it it's
great for the game and we want you to
keep it and we like the name too so we
went for them we're not really worried
about confusion although you know it's
it's a funny joke it comes up all the
time
the games are so radically different
that you know we never we never been
confused for hearthstone or vice versa
I'm quite sure yeah one thing that a my
brother Tony and I are really passionate
about is modding and the value that
players can bring to a game as they
develop content for the game whether
it's intentional or not not so for stone
hearth we baked in modding support from
in the in its bones and we want people
to mod the game we want to make it easy
to love the game and the game ships with
some of the modding tools that we use
internally in all the gaming IP eyes and
things like that and this is a mod that
one of our players has already made this
person really wanted to make like a
Candyland game and so they came in and
changed all the assets and a lot of the
models so as I harvest he's like you
know candy lollipop things they draw up
sugar cubes instead of logs and this is
just the start of the mod but this
person's vision is to like you know make
basically a total conversion of light
you know a game about building in a
Candyland and so you know modding is
something that we think can be a great
way for the development team to sort of
share ideas with the fans and vice versa
and we actively work with the modders to
make sure that they have the support
they need and you know just excited to
see what other other gamers will come up
with
[Music]